une et deux et une et deux je devrais
plutôt dire ah bin fahad il va puisqu'il
s'agit d'un cours de musculation russe
prévu que son hôte français
claudie andré deshaies et jean pierre
haigneré l'entraînement classique sans
doute réservé à tous ceux qui
fréquentent la cité des étoiles dans la
banlieue de moscou
ces 11 le tabouret tournant jusqu'à ce
que vertige s'en suive ou traditionnelle
épreuve de l'accélération dans la
centrifugeuse
habituellement cet entraînement dur buzz
en mai jean pierre haigneré connaissait
déjà pratiquement tout à faire
puisqu'ils avaient suivi en doublure les
préparatifs du vol de michel tonini
non l'exploit est plutôt du côté de la
première cosmonautes française qui a
appris le même programme en neuf mois
seulement
au cours de ce vol baptisé altaïr le nom
d'une étoile très lumineuse jean pierre
haigneré réalisera une douzaine
d'expériences scientifiques à bord de la
station mieux le matériel utilisé pour
rejoindre cette station reste immuable
vaisseau de transport soyouz dont même
la faucille et le marteau soviétiques
n'ont pas été repeints jean-pierre quand
on voit c'est vraiment tout petit on est
vraiment passé comme des pingouins ici
alors est ce que véritablement ce genre
de vaisseau encore de l'avenir
oui un avenir parce que d'abord il
montre sa fiabilité c'est un système
finalement extrêmement rustique qui
coûtent pas tellement cher et qui part
alors pour arriver là où il veut quand
il veut ce qui n'est pas toujours le cas
des navettes ni la navette américaine on
le voit encore récemment et des deux ni
d'ailleurs burhan je pense que si on
devait le mettre en oeuvre ce serait été
le cas avec hermès sont lavés avec 5
millions d'exclus en france et 230
millions qui ne vont pas très très bien
en ex urss on peut soulever la question
de savoir si 80 millions france avait
pas beaucoup pour un vol comme celui là
pour 230 millions de personnes 80
millions de francs s'est pas beaucoup
mais ça représente quand même une somme
qui permet à tous les gens qui
travaillent dans le complexe spatial de
pouvoir continuer à travailler et de
gagner leur vie d'acheter du pain donc
c'est un effort que l'on a fait pour
supporter pour un spatiale russe
d'autre part pour new 80 millions de
francs c'est ça représente à peu près
sur un programme qui dure deux ans un
fonds par français actif c'est-à-dire de
cigarettes un malabar et c'est très peu
par rapport à ce que représente l'accès
à l'orbité basse dans laquelle on peut
faire un nombre d'expériences considère
à l' aventure spatiale pour le prix d'un
chewing-gum que demander plus
le vol devrait durer 21 je vais collage
prévue le 1er juillet pour jean pierre
et ses ruelles similiaires serebrov du
moins
claudie elle sauf imprévu devra attendre
jusqu'en 1996 il lui reste encore du
temps pour faire du shopping moscou